Hallo, Sistu ist mein Arme. Ich bin die Sistu-Arztin auf der Sektation.
Ich würde gerne das Aufnahmegeschrieb führen. Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, guten Abend Frau Doktor. Aber natürlich, sie machen einen sehr freundlichen Eindruck.
Ich denke, das wird gut. Ja, bitte schön. Ich bin extra jetzt gekommen.
Danke, ich freue mich. Bevor wir über Ihre Beziehwerte erzählen,
würde ich Ihnen ein paar Argumente fragen. Wie heißt sie?
Mein Name ist Martin. Martin?
Husedom. Martin, M-A-R-T-I-N.
Das ist der Vorname, Martin.
Husedom.
Das ist Harvey Heinrich.
Hübe Ute.
Es ist Sie, nicht?
Eve Eve.
Eve Dora.
Hübe Otto.
Ich bin 47 Jahre alt.
Könnten Sie mir bitte verraten, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wegen?
Sie wollen aber viele Sachen wissen, Frau Doktor. Ich bin 1 Meter, ich glaube 75.
Und mein Gewicht ist ein bisschen viel, das sind 93 Kilo.
Herr Husedom, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 3.6.74.
3.6.74.
So, Herr Husedom, was für Sie uns, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Frau Doktor, ich glaube, ich habe einen Herzinfarkt.
Ich habe seit heute Mittag auf der linken Seite ein starkes Stechen.
Ich bekomme keine Luft und das macht mir großangst.
Seit viel, viel Tagen haben Sie es?
Das ist seit heute Mittag.
Ja, aber ich habe das schon in den letzten Monaten immer wieder gehabt.
Aber heute war es sehr, sehr schlimm.
Auch jetzt, wenn ich versuche, tief einatmen, dann sticht es und dann strahlt es hier nach vorne aus.
Und ich glaube, ich habe Angst, dass es ein Herzinfarkt ist.
Deswegen bitte, bitte schauen Sie nach.
Okay. Können wir kurz unterbrechen und ich möchte gerne Sie an der Monitor anschließen.
Ja, bitte gerne, sofort.
Dann können wir, da dünch können wir Ihre Vitalzeichnen überprüfen.
Okay, glauben Sie, das ist ein Herzinfarkt, ist Frau Doktor.
Müssen wir etwas tun, muss sie operieren.
Nein, das ist sehr früh alles zu sagen.
Lassen wir uns zuerst alles zu kontrollieren, okay?
Meinen Sie, das ist kein Herzinfarkt?
Ich meine nicht so. Ich muss sie erst untersuchen.
Okay, dann kann ich Ihnen etwas sagen, okay?
Dann machen Sie bitte schnell.
Ja, ich habe Angst, dass es ein Herzinfarkt ist.
Sie wissen Sie, mein Onkel hatte letztes Jahr einen Herzinfarkt und ist kurze Zeit danach verstorben.
Und auch bei uns in der Familie gibt es einige, die Herzinfarkte hatten.
Und bei denen hat es alles so angefangen, ne?
Ja, okay, wir gucken mal, ich werde es schon als Ihr Wunsch drücken müssen.
Okay, dann Ihr Herzfrequenz überprüfen und Sauerstoff in Blut messen.
Bitte, ja, gerne.
Mein Hausarzt sagt immer, dass es nicht das Herz, aber heute ist es echt anders.
Heute ist es anders als vorher.
Okay, okay.
Dann machen Sie sich weiter.
Okay.
Herr Hose-Dom, ich habe Ihre Vitalzeichnen überprüft.
Ihr Blutdruck ist in normalen Grenzen.
Wie hoch ist das? Was haben Sie gemessen, Frau Doktor?
Ja, 140 zu 90.
Ist das nicht hoch? 140?
Nein, es ist grenzwertig, aber es ist nicht hoch.
Ich dachte, ab 120 ist alles hoch, aber ich dachte, ah, okay.
Sie sagen, das ist normal?
Ja, das ist normal.
Ich könnte gerade sagen, dass das normal ist.
Okay, Ihr Herzfrequenz ist ein bisschen hoch, das ist 100.
Das ist nicht so hoch.
Sie sind ein bisschen aufgeregt, das kann normal sein.
Durch etwas zu sagen und Ihre Sauerstoff in Blut.
Das ist 94, wenn ich Ihnen ein bisschen Sauerstoff gebe.
Das kann Sie erreichten.
Ja, bitte. Wenn es gut tut, gerne.
Ja, es tut gut.
Wie fühlt es sich jetzt?
Ja, noch nichts.
Im Moment ist alles gleich, aber ich hoffe,
dass der Sauerstoff jetzt mir gut tut.
Ich habe eine gute Praxis für die Doktorin.
Wir können jetzt weitergehen.
Wenn Sie wieder schlichtfühlen,
sagen Sie mir, bitte 5 Schalte, dann können Sie wieder unterbrechen.
Aber wir müssen diese Gesiebratung ein bisschen führen.
Ja, okay.
Wenn Sie etwas schlichtfühlen, okay?
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch früher solche Beschwerden erlebt haben.
Und wie oft?
Das habe ich seit den letzten 3-4 Jahren immer wieder gehabt.
Aber so stark wie heute waren sie noch nie.
Das ging immer nach 1-2 Tagen wieder vorbei.
Mein Haushaltsantrag hat gesagt,
das EKG war immer in Ordnung.
Einmal hatte mich sogar ins Krankenhaus geschickt,
aber da kam auch nichts raus.
Aber heute ist es anders.
Heute habe ich echt Angst, dass es vielleicht am Herzen ist.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen,
wie viele Schmassen sind auf einer Schmaske,
von 1 bis 10, wo bei 1 Jahr leitung 10 sehr stark ist?
Also, ich würde schon sagen, so bei 7.
Wenn ich versuche, einveratmen, dann sticht es wie ein Messer rein.
Das geht bis in die Tiefe.
Ich bin nicht mehr vorne aus.
Ich kann nicht mehr atmen.
Das fühlt sich ganz, ganz schlimm an.
Gibt es eine Verbindung mit der Bewegung?
Ja, wenn ich versuche, meinen Arm zu heben,
nach hinten, dann merke ich, das zieht dann auch.
Das ist richtig.
Aber dann kann ich auch schlecht laufen,
weil ich dann nicht mehr richtig atmen kann.
Das geht auch mit einer Verbindung mit körperlicher Belastung.
Wie meinen Sie körperliche Belastung?
Wenn Sie die Treppe steigen oder lange Strecke laufen,
hatten Sie auch früher eine Schmasse?
Ja, sich merke ich schon.
Wenn ich mich körperlich anstrengen kann,
wie Sie sagen, etwas Treppensteige,
dann wird die Luft natürlich knapp.
Ich kann dann schlecht durchatmen,
muss ein bisschen Pause machen.
Danach geht es wieder.
Ich kann nicht richtig durchatmen.
Dann wird es sehr eng auf die Wurst.
Ja, es ist wie Atemnot.
Ja, genau.
Wie viele Stufen können Sie steigen,
ohne Atemnot zu bekommen?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gezählt,
aber so ein halbes Stockwerk geht.
Aber das habe ich erst jetzt seit 3-4 Tagen.
Vorher war alles in Ordnung, da habe ich gar nichts gehabt.
Das war 3-4 Tage.
Das ist die Luftnot.
Aber heute ist schlimmer geworden.
Auch die Schmerzen sind heute ganz schlimm geworden.
Können Sie flachlegen?
Ja, aber wenn ich mich drehe,
dann kommen wieder die Schmerzen.
Sie können flachlegen.
Ja, aber wenn Sie kissen?
Ja, mit Kissen ist das angenehmer.
Ich habe so ein Kissen unter meinen Rücken gelegt,
dann wird es etwas angenehmer.
Wie viele Kissen benötigen Sie in der Nacht?
Ich habe einen Kissen und ich nehme noch ein zweites Kissen dazu.
Haben Sie in der Nacht Luftnot?
Heute Nacht habe ich das Gefühl,
dass die Luft etwas knapp wird.
Ich habe mich aufgesetzt.
Nach wenigen Minuten war das wieder besser.
Aber ansonsten habe ich geschlafen.
Sind Sie deswegen aufgewacht?
Ich war wach und habe gemerkt,
dass ich etwas schlecht Luft bekomme.
Ich habe versucht, ruhig zu atmen.
Dann war es wieder besser.
Hat es Sie gleichzeitig herzerasen?
Ich habe den Puls nicht gemessen,
aber ich habe gemerkt, dass es auf der Brust zittert.
Wir sind noch zwei Kinder.
Ich möchte nicht sterben.
Meine Kinder sind noch jung.
Ich habe Angst, dass mein Herz infakt ist.
Ich verstehe, ich verstehe.
Aber das ist sehr früh etwas zu sagen.
Bitte ein bisschen, zehn Minuten.
Aber Sie schauen gleich nach.
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie seit drei, vier Tagen etwas ausprobiert,
um diese Schmerzen zu lenden?
Ja.
Ich mag keine Tablette.
Deswegen habe ich nichts genommen.
Heute Mittag habe ich eine kleine Parazita mol genommen.
Dann ist es auch ein bisschen besser geworden.
Aber eigentlich habe ich keine Tablette genommen.
Nein.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass Sie bei Ihrem Haus als veganer Menschen nicht wissen.
Ja.
Was haben Sie bei anderen Cardiologen?
Ja, da war ich vor sechs Jahren.
Ich habe eine Herzultrasche bekommen.
Damals gesagt, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Vor sechs Jahren.
Aber damals hatten Sie auch eine Schäbe.
Ja, aber nicht so schlimm.
Heute nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Ja, leider sind Sie auch chronisch.
Wie meinen Sie auch chronisch?
Wie alternativen Plutzucker?
Bisher hat mein Haushalt immer gesagt,
das ist alles in Ordnung.
Das Kolesterol ist wohl auch in Ordnung.
Er hat immer meine Laborwerte untersucht.
Also bisher jetzt glücklicher war er.
Ich habe immer gesagt,
mein Vater hatte hohen Blutdruck.
Und meine Mutter hatte hohe Skolestermine.
Deswegen habe ich immer Angst, dass ich das auch bekomme.
Wie ist Ihre Alternativen?
Ja, Sie sind aber schon sehr alt.
Sie sind auch sehr alt.
Sie haben eine andere Alternativen.
Und die werden von meiner Schwester gepflegt.
Ich habe hier family service.
Meine Schwester ist gesund hier.
Haben Sie noch andere
und ein häuser
schon gehabt, vor einem halben Jahr genau und da habe ich eine Woche eine sehr schlimme Phase gehabt
mit Fieber, mit Husten und so weiter und ich habe danach drei vier Monate immer wieder Husten gehabt
aber das ist jetzt besser geworden jetzt habe ich kein Husten nein
ja okay
ich war vor acht Jahren habe ich einen Leistenbruch gehabt auf der Rechte und das hat man operiert
aber das war gut verlaufen und bei dem habe ich auch keine Probleme ohne Komplikation
würde sehen lassen okay ja genau okay nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein nein keine Medikamente
ich will keine Medikamente ich mag keine Medikamente okay
aber mein Haus hat gesagt ich soll zum Urologen gehen weil ich jetzt in das alte für Männer komme
das ist jetzt ein bisschen peinlich aber ich muss auch manchmal nachts zum Wasser lassen aufstehen
das war früher nicht der Fall und aber auch manchmal das Gefühl dass ich öfters mal Wasser
lassen muss und mein Haus hat wie viel mal am Tag manchmal vier fünf mal in der Nacht einmal
oder zweimal und mein Haus hat gemeint ich muss zum urologen aber dann möchte ich auch nicht gerne
hin aber Medikamente habe ich nicht ist es Ihnen aufgefallen dass die dicke Beine haben
Beine nein nein nein diesen Schlang habe ich jetzt glücklicherweise keine Idee mehr keine dicke Beine
die haben mir gesagt man sie haben keine höchsten
nur Atemnot haben sie und stehende Atemnot
wenn ich eine Atme genau und wie sie schon sagte wenn ich körperliche Anstrengungen mache
zur Treppensteige oder irgendetwas trage zum Beispiel zum Auto eine Kiste oder so dann merke ich das
ja die kommenden sind sie die haben sie geimpft gegen Corona ich hatte eine E-Mfung und dann hat
einen Termin für die zweite E-Mfung und da bin ich krank geworden und mein Haus hat gesagt wir
warten ein halbes Jahr machen dann eine zweite E-Mfung oder eine dritte und da habe ich jetzt
nächste Woche einen Termin für die zweite E-Mfung haben Sie Termin genau für die zweite E-Mfung
waren Sie schon einmal oder waren Sie in Lesterzeit im Ausland nein jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht ich
war beruflich wissen die ich bin Journalist ich war vor 15 Jahren in Asien und als Journalist tätig
aber seitdem war ich jetzt nicht im Ausland ich habe auch so ein bisschen Angst vor dem Fliegen weil
auf dem Rückflug hatten wir einen einen technischen Defekt beim Flugzeug und da musste
Not landen das war dann schwierig und seitdem habe ich ein bisschen Flug Angst
deswegen nicht auslandsreisen nein mache ich nicht mehr habe ich habe große
Angst vor Flugzeugen vor Fliegen vor wieviel Jahren ist das passiert ja das war
vor ungefähr 15 Jahren haben sie immer noch Angst aber sie haben vor dem Fliegen ich traue mich
immer noch nicht zu fliegen nein habe sie nachts Schweiß schützefröst
nein habe ich nicht aber ich merke wenn ich merzen zunehmen dann habe ich an den Fingerspitzen
so ein kribbeln nicht merke auch wie es bei so ein trockenen Mund bekommen und so ein
kribbeln im Mund und das macht mir auch Angst dann denke ich mir ist es wieder ein Herzinfarkt
oder ist es ein Schlappfall dass ihre Fingerspitze bläulich sind nicht aber das kribbeln ganz
kribbeln im Mund und am Fingerspitzen wie ist ihr apetit also mein apetit ist gut ich
apetit habe ich kein problem haben sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen oder so genommen
ich habe ein bisschen zugenommen ehrlich gesagt aber nicht viel zwei kilo seit wann oder in welches
seit trauen ich glaube letztes Jahr war ich zwei kilo weniger können sie einfach durchschlafen oder
einschlafen habe ich nicht manchmal ja wenn ich so ein bisschen stress habe und so weiter oder
viel arbeite dann dann merke ich dass das mit dem einschlafen etwas schwierig ist aber
jetzt in letzter Zeit war alles gut immer sie jetzt fast dagegen nein nein ich bin mir
vielleicht mein türkisch schwarz die dann reicht nur war sie stress aber ja okay
was denken sie frage dr ist es ein herzinfarkt wenn ich so einatmen dann kommt das stechen das zieht
hier rüber das ist ein großer druck aber sie gerade fischmassen ja das wind im moment
und es nimmt wieder zu schlecht ganz schlecht
okay gerade sehe ich am monitor dass ihre vital seinen in ordnung sind ja
ja in zehn minuten körperlich untersuchen und ihre abhörte ja bitte bitte ja ja wo genau
sind ihre schmassen hier unterhalb der rippen links hier unterhalb der rippen das kommt aber
ich merke unterhalb vom schulter blatt von hinten kommt es straht nach vorne aus und dann
sticht es richtig rein und verteidigt es hier auf der brust ganz weit und wenn ich einatmen
dann dann ich kann nicht richtig tief atmen
in den des innen des innen des brustkurs oder von außen ich nicht sagen also das ist
überall überall zu zweit das sticht ein messer
in diesem okay
ee visite saas mit iran wassallasen stuhlganker wo sie probleme
hat ich ja vorhin schon gesagt dass wir den wasser lassen dass das jetzt
jetzt aber
Aber...
Aussagt schmerzen beim Wasserlassen oder...
Sonst sind wir...
Haben Sie Sortbränen?
Sortbränen habe ich nur, wenn ich etwas Scharfes esse.
Aber ansonsten...
Ich bin jetzt hier noch ein paar Informationen.
Noch mehr, Doktor.
Ach Gott, ich dachte, es ist schon fertig, Doktor.
Wie viel wollen Sie mich...
Ja, ja, ich bin jetzt hier nur fünf Minuten. Wir sind gleich fertig.
Okay?
Diese Informationen sind wichtig, deswegen muss ich...
Sie sehen, die Schmerzen nehmen zu und Sie fragen mich hier die ganze Zeit.
Ich beeile mich, ich beeile mich.
Haben Sie allergie?
Ja, ich leide an Polenallergie.
Ich habe allergie gegen Erdnüsse.
Und dann habe ich auch gegen Obst, verschiedene Obstsorten, auch allergie.
Wie Apfel, Erdbeeren und Kiwi.
Wie äußert Sie diese Allergie?
Ich kriege ihn in den dicken Hals, ich bekomme schlecht Luft.
Ich rippelte im Mundbereich und auf Äpfel hatte ich auch schon mal...
so eine ganz dicke Lippe.
Okay.
Haben Sie Unfallstiegelkeit?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich benötige noch ein paar Info über Gewohnheiten.
Rachen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Keine Rauchen.
Alkohol trinke ich auch nicht.
Auch nicht.
Das ist, Herr Huse, doch eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ach, guck.
Was glauben Sie? Nein, Gott ist für nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Verheiratet? Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass die Journalisten sind.
Arbeiten Sie immer noch aktiv?
Also ich arbeite aber nicht mal Journalist,
sondern ich arbeite mit der Schule tätig.
Ich bin dort sozial verratet.
Sozial verratet?
Haben Sie Stress am Arbeitsplatz?
Ja, immer natürlich, wenn man mit Kindern arbeitet.
Das ist schon sehr anscheinend.
Haben Sie andere Stressfaktoren, die Sie belasten können?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Wir haben jetzt ein Haus gekauft.
Ich versuche das Haus zu sanieren
und zu renovieren.
Das ist natürlich auch schon sehr stressig.
Es ist auch eine schwere körperliche Arbeit.
Das ist eine halbe Baustelle im Moment.
Können Sie diese Baustelle selbst erledigen?
Ja, ich versuche vieles noch alleine zu machen.
Wie sind Sie Herr Frau Doktor?
Das ist alles sehr teuer geworden.
Gleich zuletzt war das Haus jetzt teuer.
Die ganzen Materialien sind viel teurer geworden.
Deswegen haben die ganzen Facharbeiter für die Baustelle getroffen.
Können Sie diese Aktivitäten selbst erledigen?
Ja.
Mit der Köpelschebelastung haben Sie sich nicht bei diesen Aktivitäten?
Also bis vor einer Woche ging das ganz gut.
Jetzt ist alles sehr gut.
Ja Herr Huzedon, ich bin fertig mit meiner Arbeit.
Ja, endlich Frau Doktor.
Bitte umfassend.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich habe Angst, bitte.
Schauen Sie, ist das eine Herzinfarkt?
Ich dachte, beim Herzinfarkt macht man alles sehr schnell.
Sie machen alles sehr langsam Frau Doktor.
Und Fragen und Fragen und Fragen.
Ja, bei der Herzinfarkt,
wir sehen zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck
oder viele Tachikardi, Herzrausen.
Ich habe bei Ihnen diese Zeichen nicht gesehen.
Ach so.
Das heißt, wir haben Zeit und ich muss...
Ja, warum habe ich so stark Schmerzen?
Warum bekomme ich keine Luft?
Warum habe ich so stark Schmerzen?
Ja, ich werde Ihnen jetzt Blut abnehmen.
Und bei dieser Blutuntersuchung können wir
die Herzinfarkt ausschließen.
Ach, dann machen Sie schnell bitte.
Dann nehmen Sie Platz, bitte, in Watessima.
Ich komme in 2, 3 Minuten.
Soll ich jetzt vom Monitor weg?
Oder soll ich erst mal liegen bleiben?
Okay, sorry, Sie können liegen bleiben.
Ich komme.
Dann können wir mit der Köpferische Unterzulangen anfangen.
Okay, danke schön, Frau Doktor. Vielen Dank.
Ja.
Was ist das, das ist eine
Herzdiagnose und dann Ihre Differenzialdiagnose.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eben gerade ein Patientin mit Verdacht auf Herz-Myocard-Infarkt
eingenommen.
Kann ich diesen Patientin Ihnen vorstellen?
Okay, hat er in Myocard-Infarkt oder ist es eine instabile AP
oder sind es links-to-molkale Schmerzen?
Okay, gut.
Dann erzählen Sie mal, Frau Doktor, bitte.
Danke. Martin Huse-Dom ist ein 47-jähriger Patientin,
der sich bei uns heute Mittag aufgetretenen,
auf der linke Seite, auf der linke Seite bestehenden.
Ich sehe hende, ich sehe hende,
russischem Asen, angina pektoris mitdüsme,
folgeschtat hat.
Der Patient behtet das, sie er, seit 4-5 Tagen,
die Zeichnarschen bei Köpferli-Chebelastung hat.
Der Bericht hat er bewertet,
seine Zeichnarschen mit dem Sieben auf der Schmerzkala.
Ich habe den Patientin an der Monitor angeschaut,
seine Vitalparameter sind enorm bereich.
Welche Art von Schmerzen sind das?
Der Patient berichtet, dass wir sind stehende Schmerzen,
stehende link-to-molkales Schmerzen,
beim Einatmen.
Die Fragen nach Husten und Hemoptysi würden verneint.
Hüstenhemoptysi und ödemandanbeinen würden verneint.
Der Bericht hat eine Zweimalnokturi und eine Nocturnaldissipine.
Er benötigt zwei Kissen in der Nacht zum Schlafen.
Dauerhaft immer oder akut in dieser Situation?
Ich glaube, ich habe das nicht so deutlich gefragt.
Es sind drei Tage, die Kissen vorher nicht.
Okay, zwei, drei, vier Tage.
Der Patient berichtet, dass er nur halb ist,
steigen ohne Atem noch zu bekommen.
Nach Schweißschüttofrost wurden verneint.
Er hat kein Appetit, kein Appetanz.
Er hat berichtet, dass er in diesem Jahr
zwei Klosteren genommen hat.
Der Patient hat auch gesagt,
dass er manchmal oder wenn er es hat,
kribbelnut bereit und am Fingerspitzen hat.
Aber Zianose wurde verneint.
Zianose im Fingerspitzen wurde verneint.
Fiba?
Fiba, ich glaube, ich habe ja Fiba leider nicht gefragt,
aber ich kann bei der Körperleschung nachholen.
Der Patient hat kein Fiba.
Als für Erkrankungen, der Patient hat keine Kronischerkrankungen.
Vor einem halben Jahr hat er Corona erlitten.
Er dauerte eine Woche.
Nach dieser Infektion,
seine Alten, seine Büschne,
sieben Monate dauerte er.
Das heißt, diese Reizwurst
hat drei Monate angehalten.
Hat er immer noch Reizwurst?
Nein.
Er wurde vor acht Jahren anleisten,
beru operiert.
Die Operation war komplikationslos verlaufen.
Der Patient erwähnt,
ab und zu,
Anschlafprobleme haben,
zu haben, aber er nimmt dagegen nichts ein.
Auch sardan nimmt der Patient keine Medikamente.
Der Patient berichtet,
dass die ähnliche Probleme
für sechs Jahre auch gehappt.
Damals wurde
Ökokardiografie bei Indutsch geführt.
Aber nichts wurde diagnostiziert.
Es wurde keine Kaha-Kan Diagnose.
Keine Kaha-Kan Diagnose.
Es war keine Auffälligkeiten.
Es war unauffällig.
Als Allergin besteht
bei den Patienten
Polanalergie, Ernose, Obst, Erdbeere
und Kiwialergie.
Die Allergie äußert sich mit Düsseldorf und Ödeme.
Und Stridor.
Und Rauchen.
Der Patient ist kein Raucher.
Er trinkt keine Alkohol.
Er hat keinen Kontakt mit den Drogen.
Er hat nur eine Corona-Impfung bekommen.
Die zweite Impfung ist schon geplant.
Die Auslandsreise
wurde in Lesnia
verleinert.
Das ist eine Information.
Über 15 Jahre in Asien.
Sind diese Wichtig-Odysolität alle
der Patienten gesagt hat übermittelt?
Normalerweise im Krankenhaus brauchen sie das nicht.
Aber bei der Prüfung,
hatte er vor 15 Jahren einen Flugzeug
und hat sich gestorben.
Seitdem hat er Flugangst.
Der Patient ist Journalist von Beuruf.
Er ist verheiratet und hat 2 Kinder.
Er ist gerade,
aber ist gerade nicht als Journalist,
sondern ist Sozialberater.
Er hat die Stressfaktoren
geantwortet.
Er hat wegen finanziellen Problemen
Stress getroffen.
Er hat gesagt,
dass bis vor
eine Woche
er die Arbeit
des Hauses
selbst machen.
Er hat gesagt, dass er
seine Vater,
die Artilielle,
die Hypertonie,
die Arbeit ist gesund.
Vielen Dank.
Was ist Ihre
Verdachtsdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtsdiagnose,
ich muss,
ja,
aber Musik,
ich muss,
ja,
aber ich muss,
Okay, das heißt, Sie machen dahingehend Untersuchungen, haben Sie schon gesagt, Sie machen einen EKG,
Vitalparameter, Laborwerte, Tropinien usw. weil Sie einen Herzinfarkt ausschließen möchten.
Denken Sie, das ist ein abgutes Coronazegromisch.
Kann man machen.
Sehr gut.
Okay, das ist jetzt Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose oder auch Verdachtdiagnose.
Damit arbeiten Sie.
Sehr gut.
Und jetzt kommen die Differenzialdiagnose.
Das heißt, woran muss man noch denken?
Was kann es denn noch sein?
Welche Erkrankungen können natürlich noch sein?
Das sind die Differenzialdiagnose.
Da haben Sie mir jetzt einige aufgezählt.
Dann sagen Sie mir noch mal, was sind Ihre Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Pneumonie oder Pleuritis.
Pleuritis, okay.
Pleuritis.
Was noch?
Muskelverspannung.
Wie denn?
Muskelverspannung, okay.
Wie nennt man das?
Muskelverspannungen, wie nennt man das da im Toraxbereich?
Wohin kam eine kleine Hinweis, kleine Notiz haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, BWS.
Also ein BWS-Syndrom, wer wollen?
Wie nennt man das, wenn die Schmerzen ausstrahlen nach vorne und zwischen den Rippen schmerzen?
Wie heißt dieses Syndrome oder diese Erkrankung?
Interkostalneuralgie.
Das sind die Reizungen der Nerven, die von der Wirbelsäule kommen, unterhalb der Rippen nach vorne ziehen.
Im Rahmen eines BWS-Syndroms, das heißt Verspannungen der Rückenmuskulatur, können die Rippen nerven, reizen und dementsprechend auch solche Schmerzen verursachen.
Also wir sprechen von einer Interkostalneuralgie.
Das macht gerne solche stechenden Schmerzen, insbesondere bei Bewegung des Torax, beim einen Ausatmen, beim Bewegen, beim Ahnbewegen.
Alles, womit man die Muskulatur bewegt, führt zu einer Reizung.
Dann kann man so ein BWS-Syndrom oder eine Interkostalneuralgie.
Okay, Loran, was gibt es noch, Differenzialdiagnosen?
Was ist die Erkrankung?
Ich habe gesagt Panikattacke.
Die haben von der Flugangst berichtet, also passt das.
Angststörung.
Und warum hat er dieses Kribbeln im Mund, diese Trockenen und dieses Kribbeln in den Fingern?
Woher kommt das?
Ja, Panikattacke.
Wie nennt man das noch?
Hyperventilation.
Durch die Angst können ein Hyperventilationssyndrom auch treten.
Das kann bis zu Hyperventilationstetanie führen, dass die Hände krempfen, die Füße krempfen.
Und es kann bis hin zu Bewusstlosigkeit führen, dass die Pat hinfallen.
Veganalkaloose.
Zum Beispiel, weil das CO2 stark ausgeatmet wird, natürlich.
Aber das kommt meistens durch Angst- und Panikstörung.
Okay, ich glaube, das reicht, oder?
Vielen Dank, das war sehr gut.
Ich habe sie heute ein bisschen in die Enge getrieben.
Aber sie waren gut, sehr gut.
Ich habe wirklich so einen Patientin, der mich heute schon dreimal angerufen hat,
weil er unbedingt untersucht werden wollte.
Das ist ein Patient.
Wir können vielleicht auch noch Aufnahme machen oder nicht, aber ich glaube, wir können aufhören.
Das ist ein Patient, der hat wirklich eine Angststörung.
Der bekommt immer wieder Panikattacken.
Und das hat er wirklich seit dem Flugzeug abstürzt.
Er war in Aserbaaljan, glaube ich.
Und auf dem Rückflug ist sein Flugzeug abgestürzt.
Wirklich in den Flughafen.
Und er hatte Glück, dass das Flugzeug nicht explodiert ist
und dass die gerettet werden konnten.
Seitdem hatte er wahnsinnige Panikstörungen, Angststörungen.
Und jedes Mal, wenn irgendwo eine Muskelverspannung ist,
im nacken Rückenbereich denkt, er hat sofort einen Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz typisch.
Dieses Stechen beim Ein- und Ausatmen, bei Bewegung und.
Er hat zudem eine schwere körperliche Arbeit auf der Baustelle.
Das guckt mal hinzu.
Somit ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß,
dass es ein BWS-Syndrom ist oder eine interkostale Neurologie.
Und er hat auch keine Medikamente genommen.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich wäre es besser gewesen,
wenn er zu Hause Immoprofen oder Paracetamol genommen hätte.
Und daher denke ich,
dass meine Schädastdiagnose wäre eine BWS-Syndrom
und interkostale Neurologie.
Aber natürlich muss man ein akutes Coronazyndrom,
bei solchen Patienten auch immer,
daran denken und ausschliessen.
Das ist richtig.
Aber schwierige Patienten.